hi Bill
Michael Montoya here what do you think
is the evolutionary advantage to
humanity being both musically and
artistically creative and where do you
think this initial spark of creativity
came from Michael Michael this is a
great question and susceptible to
speculation
apparently music and art is part of the
way we communicate and it's certainly
the way you attract mates
maybe I'll just put it to you that way
musicians and artists engage other
people in a way that people who don't
use music and don't use art do not now
there's a lot of talk about songbirds in
evolutionary biology and they all have
these songs which must be pleasing to
the ears of their potential mates and
also must send messages to others of
their species well I guess two other
species as well I'm angry this is my
territory I'm looking for a mate it's a
sunny day these sort of announcements
are made by other species so you figure
humans have just taken it just a whole
nother level with albums and and record
release parties and art exhibits and art
museums and art galleries so it really
is deep within us and I think art
enriches our lives engages our brains
and stimulates us in a way that nothing
else we do does so this is the only
speculation on my part but music
especially is certainly certainly
inspires us that's for sure
so carry on Michael turn it up loud
you